hello and welcome to the first of the
hits virtual live sessions
my name is shireen darwish i'm the north
america market development manager at
thermo fisher scientific
we're excited to kick off his virtual
2020 with three real-life story
presentations
focused on why forensic dna is critical
for criminal justice
every minute that a crime remains
unsolved it's time for someone else to
become victim
hear from the people responsible for
solving crime and learn about how
they're working together to accelerate
this process
you'll find detailed information on all
three of our presenters at the top of
your screen
let's get started with our first
presentation from victim advocate
vanessa lynch
nearly two decades ago armed with my
father and my fury in the wake of my
father's brutal murder
i gave up my career in commercial law to
try to make my country a safer place
unbeknownst to me at the time this would
involve a life journey
international and more recently global
advocacy which in turn has led me to
meeting and visiting some of the most
remarkable people and places in the
world
today being no exception my first
virtual presentation with an audience
much more diverse
widespread and global than ever before
good morning good day and for sun good
evening
my name is vanessa lynch and i'm the
founder of the dna project
and today i'm going to share with you my
story which some may refer to as one of
a victim advocate
but i prefer to tell it as one of a
crusader a dna crusader if you must
victim advocates crusader civil society
activists call it what you will
being an act being an activist for civil
society
requires you to be passionate about the
things that matter to you
and the issue that i'm passionate about
is fighting crime with science
in particular dna and i'm pretty sure
that most of you who have joined us
today
share this passion for dna in some form
or another
and whilst many of the challenges i have
faced and continue to face in my own
country
may not be prevalent on your own i'm
also pretty sure that there are other
issues
as we have seen from many of the hashtag
movements recently
global issues matter everywhere and
affect people differently
my own country south africa
affectionately known as the rainbow
nation
lies on the tip of the continent of
africa and whilst hailed as truly one of
the most beautiful and diverse places in
the world
it is also one of the ugliest
gender-based violence
whilst on the decrease is still rife and
we have earned the undesirable
reputation of being the rape capital of
the world
on average 58 people are murdered daily
and we also have one of the highest
reoffending rates
and it's not just south africa that is
affected by violent crime
many countries across the world face
similar problems
but these are problems we hear of in the
news that don't affect us
this makes it easier for us to observe
them and turn away
but when my father was murdered i could
no longer be just an observer i could no
longer turn away
and so i began my first crusade in 2004
when my father's case was closed due to
a lack of evidence
and i realized that my father's slayers
had literally got
gotten away with murder members of the
public cleaned up the crime scene before
the crime scene investigators arrived
police and forensic pathologists threw
away valuable dna evidence which may
have identified the perpetrators
and there was generally a lack of
knowledge at the time as to the value of
dna evidence and proving accountability
accepting my father's murderers would
never be brought to book
was one of the hardest things i have
ever done and in an effort to ensure
that this did not happen to more
families
i started the dna project a non-profit
organization
set up to help combat violent crime in
my country
over the years my organization
consisting of no more than 10 incredibly
passionate crusaders
has changed national policy and
succeeded in lobbying government to pass
dna-specific laws which now regulate
the national dna database and mandate
that dna is collected from arrestees as
well as convicted offenders
since that time we have seen violent
offenders linked up to as many as 30
crimes from hits on the dna database
we've embarked on a national crime scene
awareness campaign and aided the
development of forensic dna
degrees in both science and law and
these are just a few of the reasons why
the dna project has been lauded as a
pioneer in lobbying for forensic dna
advancements in south africa
the second initiative based on the
successes of the first is today a global
movement
to aid other countries in africa develop
and expand their dna outreach programs
to help resolve crime
this new non-profit aptly named the dna
project africa
takes lessons learned in south africa to
other african leaders and stakeholders
as well as to victim advocates to help
identify more efficient and holistic
approaches to use dna profiling for
crime scene investigation
as well as help progress dna laws dna
databases
skills and infrastructures within their
own criminal justice systems
today i would like to share with you a
little about these two programs
and in the context of the time we have
together today i have broken this down
into what i call six lessons which i
believe translate
into ways to use the power of victim
advocacy to help build the dna database
there may be many more ways to do that
but these are the ones that work for me
and i hope by sharing them with you
today that these lessons may inspire you
to do the same
the first lesson is the most important
factor influencing the potential effect
of dna in any criminal justice system
and that is to look at what your what
your laws allow you to do with it
without enabling dna legislation you
cannot build a dna database
dna being used on a case-by-case basis
simply does not harness this incredible
power
this this technology has to offer
by passing laws which mandate the
collection of as many dna samples from
as many different categories of people
as legally possible
in order to grow a national dna database
you are not only able to identify
criminals at a much earlier stage of
their criminal career
but you save lives by preventing them
from striking again
looking globally every administration
which has used dna profiling in
conjunction with a dna database
has done so because the laws have
allowed them to do so
if you don't have dna laws in your
country it's time to start
lobbying for them now and if you do have
laws you need to ensure that they
contribute to the growth of your
database
by including as many profiles as
possible
flattening the curve is not the aim of
this critical objective
but laws alone do not affect change and
this brings me to my second lesson
crime scene awareness you may have the
best dna laws in place the smartest
scientists working in the most advanced
dna labs
but if at ground level your crime scene
investigators are unable to secure a
crime scene
in order to properly collect the dna
evidence you will never get off the
starting blocks
this is why one of our project's main
aims was to raise awareness around the
importance of crime scene preservation
and we achieved this under our dna
awareness campaign
we raised funds in order to provide free
workshops to a variety of first on crime
scene responders
as well as our general public our
trainers were highly skilled
our material was simple yet effective
and our reach was national
we then tackled skills and education
when the project was first started there
was no specific degree for forensic dna
analysis
in either law or or science at
any university in south africa we work
together with government stakeholders
and leading academics from around the
country
to develop postgraduate qualifications
at honours and master's level in both
science and law
which degrees are both available at
several universities throughout south
africa
the fourth insight i wish to share with
you is a reminder that in seeking to
convict with dna
one must never forget the power of dna
as exco poultry evidence
to protect the innocent in fact the
innocent need to be protected more than
the guilty
dna is proving to be one of the most
valuable tools in helping to exonerate
innocent people today
to this end we lobbied to ensure that
our dna laws included a provision
which allows applicants access to the
crime scene sample information on file
for exoneration purposes
without having to apply to court to
reopen the case
we also worked closely with the
innocence project of south africa as
well as a forensic science laboratory
where dna evidence could be used to help
with exoneration cases
play the video here
the dna project sets out to educate the
public never to interfere with the crime
[Music]
scene
[Music]
[Music]
the message was clear never disturb a
crime scene
the fifth lesson is what i like to call
innovative interventions
to generate support and awareness around
the value of dna to fight crime
and the video you've just seen is
exactly that
and to do this you need to ensure that
you have a good cross-section of society
on your side
and what better platform than social
media to do this
social media has the immense power to
bring together diverse and diametrically
opposed points of view
which helps bring legitimacy to your
campaign
we engage with victims human rights
activists social influencers
policy makers as well as a range of
professionals to achieve this
we also manage to produce three
hard-hitting edgy tv
adverts and secured over six million
rands with the free advertising on
national television
and what we learned through this lesson
is that crime is not discriminating
it affects everyone no matter who you
are the devastation we felt as a family
over the loss of my father had no social
boundaries
and cuts as deep whether you are a
cultural icon an ordinary citizen
a politician or an activist
my final lesson is oversight every
system requires balance
and an oversight body with
representatives from both the public and
private sector to monitoring regulated
dna database
strengthens political accountability
this holds promise for civil society
that human rights concerns will be
safeguarded
and it prevents political deviations
from the founding principles of the dna
laws
but there will always be challenges and
we have suffered some crushing setbacks
the forensic science laboratory has
recently lost the funding promised to it
on passing the laws
resulting in a shortage of necessary dna
consumables and sampling kits
which has caused a rapid decline in the
growth of our database
convicted asset offender sampling has
also been stalled
whilst our police minister tries to push
for a population database
but despite these and other challenges
the groundwork is in place
and the impact of the dna database on
crime resolution has been significant
when i first started my project in 2004
the forensic science laboratory held
about 35 000 profiles on an excel
spreadsheet
since passing the law in 2015 this
number has grown exponentially
to well over 1 million profiles on the
dna database today
and with as many as 64 000 hits
16 years ago i took a giant leap of
faith into the unknown world of forensic
dna
crime fighting and victim advocacy and
along the way i've created social
movements that have contributed to
making my country safer
and will continue to have an impact on
crime beyond the borders of south africa
so can the collective voice of victim
advocates
really make a big difference can civil
society influence and shape national or
even global policy
yes i believe it can when i first
started this crusade my mother told me i
was fighting against thunder
and perhaps i was at first but so strong
was my conviction and the belief of dna
to reduce violent crime that i leaned
into it headfirst
no matter what the challenges that face
you in your society
and no matter how hard the fight to
overcome them i believe that all of us
has within us the power to change the
world
so if you want to change the society in
which you live or perhaps even the world
i urge you to campaign for whatever it
is that matters most
to you your community our world needs
more dna crusaders
and i share these lessons today in the
hope that maybe some of you out there
may be
motivated to connect with each other and
join forces so that we can
fight crime together just as dna is the
blueprint of life
so civil society you are the key to the
blueprint for change
thank you
hello everybody uh thanks for this
digital invitation my name is
clarksvloot
i'm a forensic investigator working at
the national crime squad of the
netherlands
part of the netherlands please today i'd
like to give you a short
update why we use the rapid id
in the hender rapid hit in the
netherlands rapid
dna i should
bring this presentation together with my
colleague stephanie frazula
but she's very busy now with the project
with a project
a rapid id so is not unable to join this
meeting
for now i will explain why we use
the rapid rapid dna this
was not an easy way to start with it
because
we had to took several steps to reach
the
the goal and finally could use it in the
field
uh but i think these steps were worth
all
being because i'm i'm a forensic officer
for a long time
and i am sure rapid dna will help us
in in cases and will be a powerful tool
in
uh to tackle crime for now
i'd like to tell you a little bit of the
forensics in the netherlands
we have one national police force
forensics are divided in the region
so every region has a forensic
department
and they will do an investigation from a
burglary
rape to a murder case so all the cases
uh
there's one that operates nationwide and
that's the national crime squad or
the national police agency
they have another task of course they
are operating together
with all the regions but
the special task is fighting
a national in international organized
crime
the other part is competing terrorism
also on national
and international level i put some
some pictures in it but most cases had
to do with
large-scale investigations on drugs
so a smuggling of the but also the
production
of drugs and we have to you a lot of
problems with the production of drugs in
the netherlands
even now with crystal meth
the other task is to help the divisions
on police
water traffic police aviation bleach and
railroad paris
two pictures for example a kidnapping of
a dead screw
on international waters but also a
murder case
in all these investigations it's
necessary to identify persons
very quickly because then we can do an
immediate arrest and when you do an
immediate arrest
you have more chance for evidence you
can see
for example there is blood on his
clothes or there are
a particular glass on the shoes or maybe
a bounce on his hands
so when you have a quick identification
and you can arrest somebody the the
chance to find more evidence
is is very good very great and
also the second part a conviction and
when you have more evidence
it's easier to convict somebody the
other part is
uh not immediate arrests but to know
if we have the right guy is this really
the guy we are looking for
for maybe you have an idler an
international request from italy
if somebody is from the dragetta is
coming to the netherlands
and they asked to arrest him but we have
to be
for sure it's the right guy so sometimes
you have to need a proactive
investigation
maybe a room or a statutory
living and look if we can find his dna
and yeah then it's important to do a
quick identification and maybe he can
bring us to other criminal contacts
so another strategy then
arrest them immediately so
the idea with real-time identification
was to combine the human observation
with the scientific observation
and we had two uh five possibilities
the fingerprints dna digital aura voice
recognition and
face recognition and we know
fingerprints and dna
are the strongest one so we are looking
for possibilities
to do an investigation and an
identification
within
two or three hours and this was possible
and i will focus now on dna because
uh that was the most important uh
investigation for us in real-time
identification
just to look back and i think until now
still in the netherlands
we work on this way we find
samples on the crime scene dna
fingerprints other samples
and then we're working working working
sometimes
hours uh it could be the whole day
and then we pack the samples we certify
the samples we bring it to a van and
we'll transport it to a laboratory our
forensics laboratory in the region
then they will investigate it and pack
it make a registration
and do a second investigation maybe they
found blood
take a swab of blood and then they bring
it to our national forensic institute
where they only do the dna
investigations
they will start an investigation but
this will take a long time when you do
it very quickly maybe one day
when you're lucky but normally it will
take
days weeks and even months and that's
really true
so we had to speed up this process and
and
our idea was to not only the id
we're working now at the possibility to
do an investigation at the crime scene
so we put a rapid hit but also for
fingerprints and everything else
we put the equipment in a van
and we could do the analyze uh
now at uh a crime scene so
when you find uh maybe stabbing
find blood take a sample put it uh
in in your rapid hit
and uh you will see it we sent it to a
laboratory to the
to the database and they compare it
this could be done in in two hours
so when you're lucky you know the right
identity
uh maybe of the perpetrator or
somebody else within two or three hours
and that was the idea
um the van
is designed uh for the iso
iec 7005 norm so it's it's
it's the standard noise
there was not an easy project because
the steps
had to be taken three important
steps uh in the netherlands it's only
allowed to do dna
investigation by the credit limited
laboratories and the first time we would
work on accreditation of the national
forensic institute but that was not
possible with two companies police in
nfi
so the police started in 2018 their own
accreditation
took one year but it was granted last
year in 2019
the board said okay you have your dna
accreditation at the police now
the second step was the law because
that's not the same as the board of
accreditation who gives you permission
so in the law and we hope this will be
ready
uh this month the parliament
has to decide on it and the parliament
is split in the netherlands the first
and second parliament
and the second parliament and the fifty
bill are already
to do the accreditation by the police
already
and the investigation by the police
already
in all cases so in organized crime in
terrorist cases
and other high impact cases and we hope
the
the the second part of the parliament
will be okay this month so we can
officially start working now with
dna and people who know me i'm working
already eight years on this
this possibility and i hope we can start
really now in
uh this year the other thing we have to
solve was the contra expertise
so in the netherlands the
suspect may ask for a contra expertise
so we have to have a contact expertise
uh
available so we split the swap we use
the splitable swap
one part for the machine and one part
for contact expertise
and also in the text of the lowest and
say you know we can
divide we can divide the swap when you
blood you divide it
one part for the repetitive and one part
is
available for counter expertise
just a picture of the accreditation not
the whole accreditation just a part of
putting the swap into the rapid hit
and send the data to the nfi and when
they
receive the data the people and the
experts and the nfi
will look at the quality and compare the
data so you can have the data back
in three hours
they are totally three hours some
investigation
and data back my colleague
stephanie is working at the rapid id
as she is testing the rapid id is it
working okay
can we use blood samples salida samples
or
other samples what is the quality
can we use the sponge you
need a kind of sponsor and can we
use a part of it for contra expertise
so it's looking to several possibilities
but also possibility to use it in the
field
when this project is ready we will send
all the information to
our our head of
the forensic and he will decide if we
are going on
with this rapid dna in the netherlands
so thanks for your attention and
if you have any questions i will hear
them thank you
hello i'm mark smith and i'm the dna
database supervisor and rapid dna
coordinator at the arizona department of
public safety
in phoenix arizona i would like to thank
thermal fisher for the opportunity to
present
at the sixth annual hits conference now
we will begin to look at lasting
forging lasting partnerships with law
enforcement agencies in the state of
arizona
through rapid dna does anyone recall the
significance
of october 6 2000
it's very hard for me to see a hand
raise or the faces of the audience while
you scour your mind to recall this date
through the format of this presentation
but the big reveal
is the beginning of a franchise that was
delivered to an audience of 17 million
people this night
on television for one hour each week
this show captivated audiences as
viewership rose
and the franchise branched out into four
separate tv shows
and the uk they combined related
episodes into tv movies
later tv distribution allowed the show
to be available worldwide
by the time the finales were completed
about 800 episodes hit the airwaves
the show csi
las vegas miami new york
and cyber each episode
had key features that led to its
continued success
it all started with a crime or a series
of crimes
the csis arrived on scene in their
hummer and gathered evidence
typically in plain clothes the evidence
was returned to a state-of-the-art crime
lab full of future-esque
instrumentation the government labs
typically didn't have
or couldn't afford by the end of the
hour-long episode
they had analyzed all of the evidence
gathered solve the crime and made
arrests
the show created long lasting effects
for crime labs
investigators and prosecutors as we
tried to explain to juries of the
obstacles we have in testing every piece
of evidence
while struggling with rising backlogs
increased caseloads and the inability to
purchase some of the cutting-edge
instrumentation
presented in the show here's a brief
background
about arizona our state currently has a
population of about 7.6 million people
the department of public safety provides
lab services to more than 200 agencies
across 15 counties throughout our state
we also ranked 10th in violent crime
according to the 2018
fbi uniform crime reporting program
so what is allowed to do facing
increased dna analysis
requests and large backlogs
our lab superintendent developed an
operational vision of how our lab could
help assist investigations
and forge lasting partnerships with our
user agencies through the use of rapid
dna
if we could provide world-class customer
service and utilize emerging technology
we could also meet part of our mission
for the technical support division
at dps in june of 2013
our lab purchased rapid dna instruments
and a group of three people were tasked
with validating the instrument to
determine if it met certain requirements
for use
once it passed the validation we created
a training program
and implemented a law enforcement dna
program
through validation we were able to
determine that we could process
single source high quantity dna samples
while this limited some of the case
types and evidence we could use we were
still able to process homicide
aggravated assault and property crimes
each of the samples processed through
our rapid program
are submitted to an accredited crime
laboratory for confirmation
furthermore the operators cannot consume
any of the evidence as a part of this
program
in addition we created a standalone
database for the program
so operators could search for possible
candidates when a suspect standard was
not available
i can't cover every detail of our
program today so we can go over that in
a future talk
a lot of time was spent developing a
training program
and looking to see which agencies would
be interested
in being a part of our program we
offered it at no cost
to the agencies that were interested and
several agencies were ready to sign up
in may of 2014 we conducted our first
training class
we trained 10 operators during an
extensive 40-hour
hour class after
waiting and waiting in what seemed like
forever
the first case came in july of 2014
i'd like to go over a quick recap of
some of our success
years our program we have trained over
80 operators from 18
agencies if you remember from earlier we
service over 200 agencies
through dps so that's why our program
requires each operator
to assist other agencies and process
those cases
so we can extend the impact of our
program
our operators have processed 531 cases
and aided 175 investigations
the program has even ruled out
investigative leads in some cases which
has allowed the subject to return to
their life and not be the focus of a
criminal investigation
the investigative weeds generated
equates to a 33
hit rate i'd like to go through a few
case examples to illustrate the variety
of cases
and the impact to our community
the first case began during a traffic
stop in the middle of the night the
officer was verifying the information
from the driver and four other occupants
during this time one of the occupants
shot the officer in the face
while backup was already on the way the
suspect car circled around a building
to return more fire the backup officer
arrived on scene
and additional gun gunfire was exchanged
between the parties
the car was found abandoned early the
next morning with several bullet holes
there was blood in the rear seat of the
car where the suspect who had the gun
had been sitting near the car was a
bloody shirt with a hole through it
items were tested with rapid dna and the
dna profile obtained hit to a person in
our standalone database
they now knew who they were looking for
and found him about a week later
a jury found him guilty on seven charges
and he received a long sentence
the next case is a bank robbery from
southern arizona
the man you see in the slide walked into
a wells fargo bank
and made demands on a sheet of paper
indicating he had a weapon
after having his demands met he ran out
of the bank but left the sunglasses
you see behind the sunglasses were
tested
and the profile hit to a person in our
standalone database
police were able to apprehend him and he
was found guilty on felony robbery
charges
the next case is a child molestation
case out of the east valley
a family friend was in town for bike
week which is a motorcycle convention
that has concerts and rides
where some of the proceeds go to local
charities
the homeowners and their children went
to bed for the night and then the family
friend was found wandering the hallway
in the early morning when asked what he
was doing
he said he was looking for a towel for a
shower later that morning
one of the kids told their mother that
someone was in their room in the middle
of the night
another child revealed that he was in
her room touching her
after an examination of the room a
sample was tested from the sheets and
the seam and stain
matched the profile from the family
friend he entered a plea deal and was
sentenced to 10 years in prison
at the onset of the program we didn't
think we would be processing sexual
assault cases due to mixtures
however the type of stain produced a
good
single source profile and we began
including cases where just semen was
recovered
the next case was partial remains
located in
a shed where blood was also found
samples from the scene were brought in
and tested the profile developed from
the blood stain
was compared to a secondary standard
from a missing person
in this case rapid dna aided in the
identification of this man and also
connected two agencies who work together
to solve the
homicide the final case is out of the
west valley
there have been several reports in the
neighborhood of a peeping tom looking in
windows
while the occupants called police the
individual always eluded them
on one night the behavior of this
individual escalated and he broke in
through a window
while the female resident was taking a
shower he stood in the doorway and
watched her shower when she got out of
the shower there was a struggle between
them
but the suspect fled out of the back
door after he was gone
she noticed that there was semen on her
hand the sample was collected
and tested on the rapid dna instrument
the dna profile that was attained hit
to a person on our standalone database
the suspect was apprehended
and lived a quarter of a mile from the
victim
this program continues to provide
world-class customer service and timely
investigative information to assist in
quicker apprehension of criminals
in addition results generated from some
cases has excluded individuals from the
case
and allowed them to return to their life
in a much quicker timeline than afforded
by
traditional investigations in turn
detectives can refocus their
investigation to identify those involved
in the crime
the operators we have trained to use
this program
and the partnerships we have forged with
each agency
have been instrumental in the success of
our rapid dna program
we continue to explore the uses of rapid
dna as the technology develops
we haven't reached the finesse of csi
and solve a case in an hour-long tv
episode with commercials
but we are getting closer we're at a
two-hour mini-series
that can provide critical information to
aid an investigation
thank you for your time today and if you
have any questions
you can contact me on the email address
provided on this slide
again thank you and enjoy the sixth
annual hits conference
we hope you enjoyed those real life
stories we'll now be taking a 25-minute
break to give you a chance to visit our
exhibit and applications halls
we'll be starting the next session at 9
00 a.m pacific standard time
if you submitted a question during this
session it will be addressed
in our on-demand view which will be
available after these sessions